Edinborough the city always accidentally
pronounces Edinburgh my name is Emma
laser let's get to it before Edinburgh
was known as Edinburgh it used to be
called in Eden or done Eden this is why
the modern Scottish Gaelic name for the
city is done
Eden first half of the name done was a
Celtic word meaning fort most likely
referring today timber Castle Eden on
the other hand was the name for the area
Edinburgh is located in however some
scholars argue that the word was solely
used to refer just to the castle or the
city then when the Anglo Saxon came and
brought the Old English they got rid of
the prefix and a suffix borough meaning
fort and since then the city was called
Edinburgh with the slight modifications
to the name by various languages though
the settlement and an umbrella was found
in crammin dating back to the Mesolithic
era later on traces of Bronze Age and
Iron Age settlements have been found in
Castle Rock and Arthur's Seat the
culture of these settlements closely
resembles the Celtic culture of mainland
Europe when Romans are after the area
they discovered the Celtic brasonic
tribes which they pushed northward into
the highlands and established a fort at
crammin which they connected by road to
York after the withdrawal of the Romans
in the early 5th century the area came
under the control of the Celtic
mohtadeen II tribe at some point in the
early 7th century the town fell under
the rule of the god Odin who built a
fort somewhere within the bounds of
Edinburgh this word was called Dunedin
and this is where the first name of
Edinburgh came from during this time the
territory of Lothian came to existence
with Dunedin being its main stronghold
with the arrival of the angles the
kingdom of God hadn't started to fall
apart
in the year 638 government forces were
defeated by the king
oswald of Northumbria and edinburgh with
the lothian region came under the
control of Northumbria it was during
this time that the prefix of Dunn was
taken out and the Anglican suffix
borough was added this created the name
for the city that we still use today
Edinburgh now newly renamed Edinburgh
marked one of the most northern points
of Northumbria the exact date of
construction of the fortress on Castle
Hill is unknown however it has been
thought that the Northumbrian created a
fortress here in the 7th century but the
only indications by the archaeological
and historical evidence are that by the
end of the Edinburgh Northumbrian period
there was some form of a noble residence
on the site in the late 9th century
during the Viking Age the Danelaw was
established footing Northumbrian power
in
due to this Northumbria was unable to
protect its most northern lands and in
the tenth century Edinburgh came under
the control of the king of scotland and
973 seee the english king Edgard the
peaceful firmly gave the lands of
Lothian to kenneth ii King of Scots
thereafter ensuring that Edinborough
will remain under the control of the
Scots ever since in the 12th century
King David the first recognized the
importance of Edinburgh and established
it as one of the first royal boroughs in
Scotland protected by his royal fortress
on the slope below the castle rock it
was also during this time when Edinburgh
as merchant class developed around the
city making it a valuable port to the
Scots it was during the fourteen in 16th
century when Edinburgh became truly
important the Scottish Kingdom and was
arguably the most important city in
Scotland and embarrassed numbers for
taxation sometimes equalled the combined
figures for the next three boroughs and
the Kingdom during the Reformation and
the borough played a vital role first in
the sixteenth century it was where Queen
Mary of Scots spent most of her time and
it was also the culmination point for
the start of the War of the three
kingdoms in the 17th century King James
the sixth of Scotland succeeded to the
throne of England uniting the monarchies
in the Union the Crown's with King James
the six now the first preoccupied ruling
two kingdoms from London
the Scottish Parliament and Edinburgh
became more powerful than ever in the
seventeenth century an umbrella was
still enclosed by its medieval
fortifications making building space in
the city very scarce because of this
many buildings started to grow upwards
with some having 14 to 15 stories it was
also during this time that the class
separation started to occur with lower
floors being occupied by peasants and
farmers and upper floors being occupied
by merchants and Lords in the early 18th
century an imbalance the Scottish
Parliament in the acts of Union which
United the English and Scottish
Parliament's and moved them to London
during the 18th century and umbra became
the most densely populated overcrowded
and sanitary city in Europe it was said
that the lower-class people living at
the bottom of the streets didn't know
each other by how they looked but by how
they spelt you can see that the higher
class living in the same buildings might
have a problem with this problem that is
why it was also during this time that
edinburgh finally started to expand past
its city borders expanding northward
southwards and the draining of Norwalk
creating a beautiful park this is when
the higher classes started to move to
more cleaner and lucrative places more
outside of the city leaving the cone
Center also the 18th century is called
the Enlightenment age in Edinburgh with
some scholars calling in the Athens of
the north therefore during this time it
seems fitting to give a shout out to
University of Edinburgh the University
was founded as the College of Law but
quickly expanded into many other
colleges most notably medicine and
literature language and culture the
university played a pivotal role in the
birth enlightenment drawing scholars
from all around the British Empire there
are many notable writers scientists
doctors historians associated with the
school also to give the university some
years accreditation Benjamin Franklin of
Philadelphia visited the University and
noted that the university housed a set
of truly great men professors of several
branches of knowledge as have ever
appeared at any age or country during
the 19th century and umbrellas and has
industrialized as other cities in
Britain and therefore it lost its title
as the most populous city in Scotland to
Glasgow nevertheless an umbrella still
retained its culture and political
importance to discuss throughout the
nineteenth century during the 20th
century an umbrella was largely spared
from any major bombings during the both
world wars nevertheless the Scottish
national war memorial commemorates lost
soldiers during World War one where one
out of every three adult Scottish men
died a number now with its magnificent
architecture lining every street stands
as the testament of the old European
Scottish ways and is willing to confront
with its centuries of experience any
obstacle standing in its and Scottish
Way